Take a look at these.
This one is an
image of a flamingo.
This one is a request
to get this image.
Do you notice anything
different between them, though?
HTTP has been around
for such a long time
that the protocol still does
something that you will rarely
find in any Modern protocol
It's regular text
and can be read by a human.
The bytes being pushed back
and forth on the network
are plain, old
regular text, and can
be read by our human brains.
HTTP simplicity also
means that we can directly
interact with a protocol without
a third party library doing
any extra work for us.
Every HTTP request begins with
a unique verb called a method
and serves a specific purpose.
We already know GET and
POST, and although these
are the most common
methods, there
are other methods you
will encounter regularly.
The common set of methods
consist of GET, POST, PUT,
DELETE, HEAD, and OPTIONS.
We will talk more
about these methods
when we talk about REST APIs.